Kourtney Kardashian is a hundred percent  over Scott Disick this from a source  close to the Kardashians who adds she is  the happiest she's been in a really long  time until now it hasn't been an easy  time for Kourtney she had Scott split in  July after he was caught canoodling with  a former flame and in October the  embattled reality star checked into a  drug and alcohol rehab center for  treatment our source says that Kourtney  knows Scott is an attic and it will take  him more than just one rehab visit to  get better and that she is quote just  over at all but will always have a  cordial relationship with Scott for the  kids our source says the mom of three is  even dating but does that mean more kids  in the future well I'm sure she'd be  open to it if she met another guy but  she's 36 and is happy with her three  kids